[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واللي عايز يجرب
احنا ما بنهددش حد
احذر نعم احذر هذا الفيديو فقد يكون مليئا
بالمفاجات انها الدوله الاكثر اثاره للجدل
على وجه المستديره قد تكرهها او تحبها
ولكنها ساهمت في نصر عزيزا على عدو لدود
نعم انها كوريا الشماليه والتي مدت يدها
بالمساعده لمصر في أحلك الظروف وها هي
التي لم تعترف باسرائيل الى يومنا هذا اذا
ما هي جذور العلاقه بين كوريا الشماليه
ومصر وكيف ساهمت بيونغ في احراز النصر
العربي الوحيد على اسرائيل ولماذا لم
تعترف كوريا الشماليه باسرائيل وماذا فعلت
اثناء الاحتجاجات في مصر عام 2011
المصالح تتصالح قد يبدو الامر غريبا لك يا
عزيزي فلماذا تحافظ كوريا الشماليه وهي
احد الذ اعضاء الغرب على علاقتها مع مصر
والتي كانت احد اهم حلفائه ولكن اذا عرف
السبب بطل العجان فجذور العلاقه بين كوريا
الشماليه ومصر ترجع الى عهد الزعيمين جمال
عبد الناصر وكم السوند وكما يقولها
المصريون المصالح بتتصالح فقد وجد كم
السونغ في توجهات ناصر الاشتراكيه خير
حليف ولو على المستوى الاديولوجي فقط
ناهيك عن ان مصر في عهد ناصر كانت تشارك
كوريا الشماليه العداء الشديد لبلاد العم
سام ولان عدو عدو صديقي فقد اصبحت القاهره
احد اهم اصدقاء بيونج المقربين
صداقه عاديه ام دفاع مشترك رغم بعد
المسافه لم تكن العلاقه بين كوريا
الشماليه ومصر مجرد علاقه جيده بين بلدين
فقد كان كيم ال سونج من اوائل الداعمين
لعبد الناصر في جميع حروب ففي العدوان
الثلاثي على مصر عام 56 كانت كوريا
الشماليه حاضره وفي حرب اليمن عام 62 كانت
كوريا الشماليه حاضره حتى في حربي يونيو
عام 67 او ما يطلق عليها باسم النكسه
والتي انهزمت فيها مصر امام اسرائيل كانت
كوريا الشماليه حاضره ايضا حاضره حاضره
حاضره حاضره ما هذا الهراء فل تعطينا
قليلا من حضورها يا هذا لكي نصدق ما تتحدث
عنه هم هم لا تستعجل يا صديقي
فل تترك
دعمت كوريا الشماليه وبشده تامين قناه وفي
السبعينات بعثت كوريا الشماليه طيارين
مقاتلين للقتال الى جانب المصريين خلال
حربهم مع اسرائيل واوفدت خبراء انفاق لمصر
لتقديم الدعم في هذا الشان لم نكمل البعض
يا هذا في التسعينات اشترت مصر صواريخ من
كوريا الشماليه كده كتير كما يقولها
المصريون اذا حان وقت رد الجميل حيث
انطلقت شركه اوراسكا للاتصالات المصريه
وعملت في انشاء كوريال وذلك في العام 2008
وهي حاليا المشغل الوحيد لشبكه جوال الجيل
الثالث في كوريا الشماليه ولا ننسى انكم
لا يامن اي شخص او كيان او دوله بشان خدمه
الاتصالات وخوفا من التجسس فقد استامن مصر
على هذه المهمه
مصر في مازق
رحل جمال عبد الناصر واستلم محمد انور
السادات مقاليد الحكم في مصر واصبح عليه
عبء تحرير الارض من اسرائيل جاء عام 72
ليقوم السادات باتخاذ قرار كان الاكثر
اثاره للجدل حينها بل وحتى اليوم وهو
الاستغناء عن خدمات الخبراء الروس في
الجيش المصري خرج السوفيات ووجد السادات
نفسه في مازق فقد اصبح هناك عجز في
الطيارين المدربين على قياده طائرات من
طراز 21 الروسي الجيش المصري يحتاج الى
طيارنا ماهري وباقصى سرعه لخوض معركه
التحرير تاتي الرساله من كيم ال سونج
للسادات لا تقلق عدونا واحد ونحن معك حتى
النهايه فماذا فعلت كوريا الشماليه
سنقاتل معكم
ارسلت للجيش المصري نحو 1500 خبير عسكري
بالاضافه الى 20 طيارا من ذوي الخبره
الكبيره في القتال والذين قتلوا ضد القوات
الامريكيه من قبل ناهيك عن عدد اخر من
طائرات كوريا الشماليه وطيارها والذين
قاتلوا جميعا في حرب اكتوبر بجانب مصر
وكانت مهمتهم الاساسيه هي حمايه صاعد مصر
من اي هجوم اسرائيلي ووجه مقاتل كوريا
الشماليه طيران مباشره وانتصر الطائره
الميج 21 على طائره الفانتوم المتطوره
التي كانت بحوزه اسرائيل وبالطبع عزيزي
المشاهد هذا لا يعد انكارا للمساعدات
الكبرى التي قدمتها الدول العربيه كالعراق
والجزائر والسعوديه وغيرها لمصر في تلك
الحرب ولكننا اذا تحدثنا عن تلك المساعدات
فلن يكفي لسردها فيديو واحد وعلى ايه حال
استمرت العلاقه الجيده
بيننا حتى في عهد الرئيس المصري الراحل
محمد حسني مبارك ومن اكثر المواقف المعبره
لتلك العلاقه انه في فبراير عام 2011
وبينما كان مبارك يودع حكمه ارسلت رساله
تهنئه لمبارك بقدوم السنه القمريه الجديده
وليس هذا فحسب بل ان حكومه كوريا الشماليه
قد حجبت عن مواطنيها اخبار الاحتجاجات في
مصر وكانت ترى ان خطيئه مبارك الكبرى هي
تحالفه مع امريكا والغرب والذين غدروا به
في النهايه كما يفعلون دائما
لماذا لا تعترف باسرائيل
العلاقات الكوريه الشماليه الاسرائيليه هي
علاقات عدائيه للغايه ولم تعترف كوريا
الشماليه مطلقا بدوله اسرائيل وتدينها
بوصفها امبرياليه فمنذ عام 1988
تعترف بسياده اسرائيل بل اعترفت بدوله
فلسطين على كل اسرائيل باستثناء مرتفعات
الجولان التي تعترف بها كجزء من سوريا
فيما تعتبر اسرائيل حكومه كوريا الشماليه
وبرنامجها النووي تهديدا للسلام العالمي
وهنا مربط الفرس حيث ضعت اسرائيل المجتمع
الدولي الى التحرك تجاه الامر وبالمقابل
هددت وهاجمت وسائل الاعلام الحكوميه في
كوريا الشماليه دوله اسرائيل عده مرات الى
اولئك المطبعين او المنبطحين
فلتتعلموا ولتاخذوا هذا الدرس من زعيم
كوريا الشماليه حتى وان كان الديكتاتوريا
في نظر العديد والان السؤال لكم مشاهدينا
كيف تفسر قرار السادات بالاستغناء عن
الخبراء الروس وهل ترى ان يمكن ان تكون
حليفا قويا للدول العربيه وتقدم لها اكثر
مما يقدمه الغرب اخبرونا في صندوق التع
ليقات
[موسيقى]